بين حريه التعبير والتحريض على العنف على
منصه تويتر خط فاصل يقف على احد جانبي
المالك الجديد الى ماسك متخبيطا وعلى
الجانب الاخر تقف مؤسسات دوليه ومستخدمون
رافدون لتوجه المنصه الرقميه تحت اداره
ماسك يوما بعد اخر تتزايد الضغوط على رجل
الاعمال اخرها تعليق حساب مغني الراب
الامريكي المثير للجدل كانيوسست بعد قرار
بعودته بذلت قصار جهدي رغم ذلك انتهى كم
مره اخرى قواعدنا ضد التحريض على العنف
سيعلق الحساب
لم يمضي وقت طويل على عوده حساب ويست
وتنشيطه ثم ترحيب بالعوده الى المنصه
ليتراجع ماسك عن قراره عقب السلسله
تغريدات ويست المعاديه للساميه والمؤيده
للنازيه
[موسيقى]
قد يواجه الى ماسك مزيدا من التخبط بعد
وعوده بالعفو عن جميع حسابات تويتر
المعلقه
ماليه او حضر في حال عدم الامتثال للقواعد
الاوروبيه الجديده المعروفه باسم قانون
الخدمه الرقميه ما زال هناك عمل ضخم امامه
سيتعين على تويتر تنفيذ سياسه شفافه
وتعزيز الاشراف على المحتوى ومعالجه
المعلومات الكاذبه بحزم والحد من
الاعلانات المستهدفه
ابواب الضغوط المتسارعه على تويتر تتزايد
يوما بعد اخر بعد استحواله منصه الرقميه
من خلاف تسريح نحو 50 في المئه من
الموظفين الى خلاف توثيق حسابات
المستخدمين وصولا الى خلاف الكبرى شركات
المعلنه على المنصه
بعيده عن رؤيه واضحه للقواعد المنظمه
لادارتها في عهدك ما قد يؤثر سلبا على
سرعه تعافي المنصه اقتصاديا علي السمان
العربيه